Hi, Robert.
Hey, Andy, how are you?
Good, how are you?
I'm good, thank you.
I'm gonna join in a second time for my PC so you can see my smiling face.
That's.
One second.
Sure, I'd love that.
First Wednesday, this.
Here's my smiling face.
There we go.
You.
Seems like we did this. I think we've rescheduled so many times. Why does it feel like we did this like 2 weeks ago?
It feels like that. Days are just fast and really, really quick this time. You're over. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's really been a month?
Oh, Lord, have mercy.
Yeah.
I'm aging faster. I'm aging faster.
Abe.
How's your Easter, by the way?
Easter is wonderful. I'm A Jesus follower, so it's one of my most favorite holidays.
Spend some time with my family. We don't, we didn't go to church. That's the day where there's too many people know where to park. I just hung out with my family.
Any.
Mhm.
That's good. Nice to hear.
How about yourself?
Myself, well, April 3rd I was in the office working.
Bombs.
No fun, Robert, by the way.
Been there. I've been there, done it. Been there, done it. Trust and believe.
Yeah, I think I've been doing it for like what, past 10 years, man. So.
Yeah.
I understand.
Anyway, but yeah, it's fine. I slept over over the weekend, so it's a that's a way to recharge. But yeah, this is our.
Amen to that.
Yes.
monthly business review. So I'm just going to share my screen.
And you know, you know, Justin already. So
I do, what's up Justin?
It's here.
Hi, yeah, yeah. Nice to see you again. Nice to see you again, Robert. Yeah.
Right.
This year.
She was well, sir.
All right, so this is for the kind of latter part of Feb and early parts of March as well.
Made it last, sorry. So agenda, check-in highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, or way forward and our recap, it's the same. So for the check-in, how are things with Lawrence? Any green?
Yep, no problem.
Beige red flags that you have seen.
None. He's good. He's amazing. He comes in, puts his boots on and works every day. He's so good.
Good to hear. Good to hear that. I don't think I ever hear any complaints about this guy, man. I mean, no news is good news, but here we go.
He's amazing.
Yeah, he's amazing. Yeah, he's just, you know, this is, it's character, you know, you know, so once you match good character with the skill set, everybody wins. It's, you know, it sounds simple, but, you know, we've interviewed hundreds of people, you know, and it's, you know, it's like you get one.
Yeah.
True.
Exactly.
Here like.
Maybe they're a good match, right? Then you hire them and they're not who they said they were. Yeah, it's hard out here to keep good people, man. So yeah, he's awesome.
PH.
Ashish.
It is.
And I'm pretty sure this is not just spilled overnight, right? So it's spilled day in, day out. And he did put in a lot of work in there in order for you guys to actually understand him and understand the nuances of how he works. So appreciate that.
Yep.
Yeah.
Yeah, and again, when I, I'm sorry to cut you off, I think I've been the service manager for maybe 2 years.
Mhm.
And he was not our best tech two years ago, right? We gave him feedback, he responded, now he's amazing.
Mm-hmm.
Right, it all sounds so simple.
Yeah.
Yes, that sounds like a success story, Robert. It is.
Yeah, he's amazing. He's amazing. He always had, he always worked hard, right? So then, you know, you give him some feedback, then he's working smarter. And once you work smarter and you communicate, easy as pie. Yeah, and I don't say this about all my texts. Yeah, this isn't the standard spiel I give to people, you know?
Mhm.
Just improve.
I gotcha.
Mhm.
Um, unless they deserve it, but he's awesome, right? He he puts in the work and it shows.
Gotcha. Appreciate that. Well, putting in some highlights in there. Appreciate your positive CSAT yet again. Thank you very much. That's for the month of Feb. And then I don't know why is this a highlight anymore, but he exceeds his KPI target. So I think the last time that we talked.
Yeah.
with, forget me, I'm so bad at names. What's his name? Donald. Donnie. God.
Donnie. Donald. Yeah, Donnie. Yeah.
Thank God, I remember it. So Donald, he did mention that you guys were doing some sort of dashboard as well, so that we can actually see the metrics for, not just for Lawrence, but for everybody, and actually see if it's accurate on how we track it on our side of things. So I just wanted to ask.
Yeah.
Was there any progress on that?
I'm gonna put you on hold one second. I got my washing machine repair guy at the door. Hold on.
Sure.
Okay, I got to get that to me. Give me two seconds. Or actually, I'm going to pass them to my wife. One moment.
Mm.
Ignore.
Kour.
Great.
Over.
As a virgin of a West, popular to do
The 2 main.
LM box.
Team.
Oh.
And these readers have been underneath.
That kills one.
So, some should beer.
American.
Monster.
Okay.
Thank you, sir. Yeah, let's not.
Watch out, watch out!
God bless you. Thank you for your patience.
Yeah, you just meet yourself, Mae.
There we go.
Yeah, life happened. Life is still happening, even though we're in a meeting.
I think we were talking about Lawrence's stats.
That I agree, that's completely fine.
Dashboard.
Yeah, the dashboard for Lawrence. I'm not driving that. Well, fortunately, I'm not driving it. I'm driving everything else. But that's in progress. Again, I don't know.
Mmh.
Okay.
Mhm.
I think it's going to be a few months probably. We're migrating from ConnectWise to Halo, and that's going to be part of it, getting all that data correctly. So it's coming. Just keep it on there for the next three meetings. We'll be good.
Gotcha. All right.
Mm.
Okay.
Understood.
Okay, I gotcha. I'll keep that in mind. Next would be action tracker. So we did submit a CSAT for the month of March. See if you can send that over. And if you haven't seen it, let me know. We'll re-trigger it for you.
Yeah.
Retrigger it for me. Yeah, I try to hit those first. If you sent it, I didn't see it. And it's not, I'm not saying you didn't send it, but I get a lot of emails, as you can probably imagine.
Okay.
Sure.
Yeah, that's okay. That's okay. I can't keep up with mine anyway. I'm sorry.
Yes, if you can resend it. Yeah, so if you can resend it, I'll let you guys know everything's all good.
Yeah.
Sure, gotcha. And for the MSP bot access, I'm not, you're still using this, right?
We use MSP bots, but that aligns with the same thing as the individual dashboard.
Mhm.
Yeah, so.
But the data's not good, so that's pretty much the same topic.
Okay.
Love it.
Cool. Gotcha. All right.
And again, we may be able to get you guys a dashboard from Halo.
Cotes.
Yeah, exactly. So that would be, I think, much easier because we're using Halo also, so it would be easier anyway.
Right, OK.
Ideals.
Yes.
Kour.
All right, so let's move on to performance analysis. So utilization trend. So the goal is 80%. He did reach 40 hours per week, which is 100%. So he did pass the work for the FEB and.
As well as with with March, so...
There's just a lot of billable hours that he's putting in. I just wanted to know also, he's been, I'm not sure, I haven't seen the time sheet just yet. It's pretty much Rodge, but have you seen any type of discrepancy when it comes to the time entries that he does put in?
Yeah.
There's not really a discrepancy, but one of the things that's changed with the way we operate is probably about...
I want to say probably five or six months ago, our dispatcher left.
Mhm.
Right, and we did not bout fill her. So the techs have an ongoing ticket to dispatch. They're basically triaging the board, updating tickets and all that good stuff when they first come in. So there's some of his time is that, right? So.
Mm.
Yeah.
I know you guys look at billable and non-billable time. So from our perspective, that's non-billable, right? But from your perspective, it's admin time, right? So I think a lot of that, where we're getting over 100, and I know we had this discussion last month, this is not all ticket.
Yeah, I get you.
True, it's admin time. Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, with Donald, yeah.
Right. It's also the dispatch time managing the board, watching the board. We're just team managing it. Like when I'm not in, I watch it when I can. I think I'm probably primary, but right now someone has to do it.
Exactly.
Okay.
Mhm.
And I'm still a manager, right? So when I'm in vendor meetings, client meetings, working tickets, somebody has to do it. So kind of the culture of our team is everybody has a ticket that they open daily and put that time at a dispatch.
I gotcha.
True.
It is.
Gotcha. I hear you. I think for the next MBR that we have, I'll probably have a more detailed understanding or showing you guys how the utilization works so that we're not just saying it's a, you know, 100% that we're hitting it. I think there needs to be a category so that you guys know what time or.
how much time he's been spending on triaging and he's spending on tickets. All right. So I'll do that. I'll work with him on it. So you'll have a rough idea on what it would be like for Lawrence. And man, for the dispatcher, don't you want to look for a service coordinator through ITBD?
Yeah.
Every single day, my direct manager, Donnie, says, Robert, what do you need?
You know, a funny story, I was doing, I was, I was doing triage and dispatch from before, like, I don't know, 5, six years ago, and I was, I was doing, I was a service desk lead back then, and I was flying to Vegas at that time, but because my, my current, the primary triage and dispatch is out of the office, out sick, I was doing the dispatch on flight.
Everyday.
The.
You were probably amazing at it.
Um, on flight.
Ohh, man, I love that for you.
Yeah, that was, I was like, oh my God, I got nothing. I have no choice, but it just, I had to do it, so.
Yu.
Sounds like you had good internet though, that's good.
Well, they paid for the internet and the flight, so...
Of course you got to buy the internet. Yeah, of course.
Exactly. So, yeah.
Yes. So I know we need a dispatcher. My team knows we have a dispatcher. We need a dispatcher. I also need two more techs. But they say, Robert, we're working on it, so we're working on it.
Mhm.
Okay, I'm just just pushing for...
Um, I, yeah, I, yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, just pushing for that. You know why? Because I know that he's doing triage in this batch, but I wanted also to give Lauren an opportunity to do something else, like wider his horizon when it comes to technologies, right? The ones that you guys are doing, the certifications around it. So CDP is part of the partnership, as you know already, you filled that out.
Yeah.
So that's part of the things that we wanted him to undergo. And we wanted him to actually have a career with us, both of us, ITBD and OmegaCore as a partner. So probably those admin time, that's why I wanted to show it also. So if those time are spent learning and understanding and getting a rough idea of where he wanted to go.
I think that would be beneficial for the both of us and for you guys, since it's he's gonna apply it on Omega Core itself, so...
Yeah.
Yeah, so yeah, and I'm glad you mentioned that because I was going to say the same thing. I think, you know, if we're going to look at his time, it should be billable time, non-billable time, and training, right? Because they, you know, if they're not doing anything, go train, go learn something. I'm all for that.
Yep. Yes, definitely.
Exactly. So yeah, that's what you're going to see in the next month. Yeah, every MBR that we have, Robert, I'm going to push for that additional resource.
Yeah.
The
So, please.
I'm kicking in. Now, for some context, Donnie's only been with Omega Corp for about maybe eight months, but two of my two jobs ago, he was my manager as well. So we know each other. We're really good friends. So he knows when I, he knows what I'm going to tell him when he asks me. I don't care where the person comes from.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Good.
I got you.
Okay.
True, you just need the role and the person filling in. That's it.
That's it. Yeah, that, you know, this is higher level executive stuff. You know, CEOs don't like to backfill, especially when you can use the people you have to already get the job done.
I gotcha.
True.
Right, but there's always something not getting done if we're doing another role that we already had. So, and those these, yeah, there's always somebody and it's usually me and.
It.
Falling through the cracks.
Mhm.
We just need the right person to say we can hire and then we're going to hire. And again, personally, I don't care where the, I don't care where the person is. I just need somebody, somebody that's good.
Yeah.
You just gotta hire.
Just gotta hire, and you know it's always about money. I understand it's a business.
True budget.
True.
I do not want to go that level in the company or in the meetings. Trust and believe.
No.
Okay.
But.
Sure, I'm just, I just wanted to listen. No, yeah, go ahead. Yeah, I gotcha.
I don't want it, I don't want it.
So thank you for that. And again, it'll probably align better with the way we were looking at stuff. But again, at this point, I'm not concerned about whether Lawrence is working or twiddling his thumbs. I know Lawrence is working.
Mhm.
Yeah, well, we know that, yeah, Bajaj, right?
Yeah.
Move on, ticket closure. So looking at this numbers for Feb and for March, I'm actually happy and glad that we have this because that means that he's not just about, you know, doing the admin work when he has a ticket. It's pretty close to the number that he gets and the one that he calls also.
So that means he pushed for that resolution, like the first day resolution that we have. So this is pretty much expected out of him. And as for the week that he failed, to be honest with you, it's not really failed for him, but it's just a failed.
Yeah.
by the standard of closing 8 to 10 tickets a day. But if you do triage and dispatch and you're not just twiddling your thumbs while waiting for a ticket, then you're still productive. So.
Vishal.
Yep, not worried about him. I'm fine with those numbers. And failure is still a win.
Ms.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Because he took the, you know, typically failure for Lawrence is he took it to a point where he didn't have the skill set, right? He escalated, he did a proper escalation, so we ain't worried about it.
True, he followed process, so...
He followed the process, yeah.
Gotcha. Next is create an updated service desk, including additional SLA metrics, as discussed. This would be down the line since we talked about that Halo PSA. Next is our enforcing, encouraging Loren's strong performance.
Yep.
maintain momentum. So for that, I'll be putting in the admin, the billable, and as well as the training so that we can actually talk more about that. Next would be, he is asking if he can take the May 25th off since it's moved.
That works.
Memorial Day, your side. Are you guys still working?
It's our, it's our memorial. Yeah, we're off Memorial Day.
So, he, he's not gonna, we're close.
So...
Yeah, okay, so I'll.
Well, he doesn't have to work. Yeah, we do on call on holidays.
All right, so I'll make sure that I'll reach out to HR and let them know that he can be tagged as off at that day.
Yes, please.
All right, I think that is it. You know, Team GPS. I know how it works. Also, by the way, since we're talking about ITBD, we have build it, man. August 3 to 5, if I'm not mistaken, you're coming.
Please do.
Probably not. I don't have time for this meeting.
Come on, you'll meet me there. You'll meet the team.
Well, I...
I don't have time for this bill, this meeting. When is it though?
August.
And is it is it in Florida? Is it in Florida?
Third C.
Jersey.
It's in Jersey, okay. I don't know.
New Jersey, yeah.
We may be going. And when I say we, it's probably our CEO and, you know, more of the executive team. I just don't know what they have. I know I'm not going. Because like when you when you travel with your company, work doesn't stop.
Mhm, mhm.
It piled up, yeah, I know.
So I have work at home and then they want to talk about work the whole time. I don't want to do that.
Well, yeah, I work at the hotel anyway, so I know.
But yeah, sometimes Alex and Abegail go to those things and I'm sure they're aware of it. But yeah, if you...
Yeah, if you can extend that though.
I haven't gotten, I usually get an email. Let me see. I usually get an email about those.
I'm just proactive. It's months prior, but you should be able to receive an email. But I'm just being proactive and asking you to join, Robert. So.
But I know for the last few years, our folks have gone. Okay, it's...
Got it.
Okay.
Yeah, again, I don't know if it's going to be me, but we'll be there will probably be somebody in an Omega Kour shirt. I think we've gone the last three or four years.
I.
Gotcha. Understood. Yeah, if you can probably extend that and if you happen to hear anything confirmation, let me know. I'll have.
Yeah.
When is it?
Um, August 3rd to 5th.
I'll be there. That's my birth month, man.
Cool.
Oh, happy birthday. My birthday's in September.
Don't tell me it's 11.
September 14th.
Okay, right after, two days after. Three, three, three days after. Gotcha.
Yeah.
Okay, uh, yeah, let me know if they're they can come.
Hold on, you're coming to Jersey?
Yes.
I love that. I love that for you.
Yeah, this is part of the job.
Well, that's a win. That's good.
Yeah, so...
I think, right? Is that good for you? This is good for you, right?
I should say yes, because this is recorded, Robert.
Ha ha!
Right, this, yes, this is definitely good for you.
Yeah, definitely great for me.
And I have Justin listening. So yes, it's great. Good opportunity. Yeah, definitely.
So yes, we're in agreement. We're both nodding, right? Yeah, this is good. Definitely good for you. Well, if I show up, I will let you know before we get there so we can, or I'll, I'm sure you guys will be available. But I'm not planning to go because like me, I'm not excited about going like you are.
Yeah.
Definitely.
I.
But we'll see, we'll see what happens.
Lucky you. I gotcha. All right.
Yeah, I don't, I know in these meetings I seem like I'm an extrovert, but I'm pretending. I'm an introvert and I don't like people.
Mhm.
to be honest with you, I said it with, I think to one of my team leads, I said, you know what, my personality and my chosen of career is really questionable, really questionable. I don't know why I'm here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Give me one, give me one second, Andy. What's up?
Sure.
Did he fix it?
It's gonna cost 6 something.
I'm about to get off this call, Andy.
It's OK.
Judy calls, the guy needs me. Thank you. Yes, close the door. Close the door.
Fix the washing machine, please.
Have a good day, Robert.
All right, thank you. Bye.
Bye.
Bye, Robert, have a good day.